Breaking news!
The door opens for regularization
massive number of foreigners in Spain.
The congress of deputies
has just approved the consideration
of the popular legislative initiative
in order to regularize hundreds of thousands of citizens.
foreigners who are in a situation
irregular in Spain
since before November 1,
2021.
This vote does not mean immediate regularization,
but the beginning of the parliamentary procedures
previous
so that this initiative can become law.
In case you get ahead,
this regularization
extraordinary
will be the most widely approved in Spain.
The objective of this initiative is to regularize
about 500,000 foreigners in an irregular situation
and has been backed by more than 600,000 signatures,
as well as for more than 900
organizations
and various institutions of relevant importance.
Undoubtedly,
today is 1 Great day for foreigners in Spain
and let's hope
that the year 2024 will also be the year in its entirety.
What do you think of this measure?
If you have any questions,
please feel free to contact us.
And remember,
follow us for more videos